foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory while there are likely
many Wizards that come to mind when you
think of Harry Potter and evil Gellert
Grindelwald and Lord Voldemort to name a
few the title of most evil which may not
be quite so obvious so in this video
we're going to be discussing why I
believe that the most evil witch in the
Harry Potter universe is one gomla gaunt
now I know what you may be thinking who
in Merlin's beard is Gormley gaunt
wouldn't Bellatrix the strange be the
obvious choice for most evil witch could
she possibly be more evil than Bellatrix
the literal Mistress of evil reincarnate
well of course Bellatrix was a truly
evil bit a witch she performed some
incredibly cruel and heinous acts of
magic and non-magic for that matter in
the name of being one of Lord
Voldemort's Death Eaters in fact the
rumor is that Bellatrix was so devout to
Voldemort in the dark arts that she
actually fell in love and was intimate
with the dark lord himself producing a
daughter named Delphi taking the vows of
a Death Eater quite above and beyond if
you ask me but anyway in addition to her
absolute loyalty to Voldemort Bellatrix
was also involved in some of the most
disturbing acts of dark magic described
throughout Harry Potter for example she
took part in the torture of auras Frank
and Alice Longbottom an act which drove
them both mad and permanently landed
them in Saint mungo's Hospital for
Magical maladies and injuries for the
remainder of their lives she also
committed many a murder including that
of beloved house self Dobby her own
cousin Sirius Black and her niece
nymphadora Tonks and she did all this in
the name of pure blood Supremacy and the
Dark Lord's vision of The Wizarding
World so yes of course it's true
Belichick's Lestrange was a monstrously
evil witch but hundreds of years before
there was Bellatrix Lestrange there was
an Irish Witch by the name of Gormley
gaunt whose acts of unspeakable evil
rival missile strangers to the point in
which I must admit that in my opinion
she was indeed the more evil of the two
so first things first who was Gormley
gaunt well as I'm sure you've deduced by
her surname gormla was part of the House
of gaunt a prominent fanatically
pure-blooded lineage in Europe the
gaunts are among those listed in the
sacred 28 a directory of pure blood
Wizarding families which was created in
the first half of the 1900s they were
enormously proud of their ancestry as
they were the descendants of Salazar
Slytherin one of the four founders of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry and a believer of pure blood
Supremacy and Cadmus pevrel the most
arrogant of the three brothers who
originally possessed the Deathly Hallows
and served as inspiration for the tales
of the Three Brothers Tom Riddle who of
course became Lord Voldemort was also a
member of the House of gaunt as was his
mother Mary pigon's daughter of marvolo
with relatives like these it's not too
hard to imagine that gomla would be one
of the nastiest witches to have ever
lived of course gomla was around long
before Voldemort and well after Salazar
Slytherin and Cadmus peverel as she was
born in the latter part of the 16th
century much of what is known about
gomla's life actually revolves around
her famous niece is old Sayer one of the
founders of ilvermorny School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry the North
American School of magic located among
Massachusetts Mount Greylock in fact it
is her actions towards assault and his
old immediate family that in my opinion
have Garnet had the title of most evil
witch in The Wizarding World of Harry
Potter let's take a look shall we as you
may recall the gaunts were so intent on
the preservation of their pure bloodline
that they would often marry their own
cousins so it's definitely not an
understatement to say that the house of
gaunt was fervent in their belief of
blood purity
gomla was no exception like many of her
ancestors she possessed the ability to
speak in parcel tongue a rare Talent
which allowed her to communicate with
snakes this was just one of the gifts
passed down to gormla from Salazar
sutherin and she was also in possession
of this powerful Wizard's original wand
it is known that gormley's sister did
not share in the family's extreme
anti-muggle sentiments and the two were
rather estranged however although they
were not familiar gomla knew that her
sister had produced a daughter is old
gomla also became aware that her sister
and brother-in-law were secretly helping
unsuspecting Muggles with minor maladies
and farm work and so it is said that
gormla was so horrified by her sister's
friendly interactions with local Muggles
that she became concerned for her
niece's future how could she allow a
pure blood ancestor of Salazar Southern
to grow up a blood traitor intermingling
and aiding a non-magical folk and so
gormla in an effort to redirect his
old's life killed her own sister and her
sister's husband by burning down their
home with the two of them inside but not
before rescuing exalt from the fire it
would seem that in gormner's Twisted
mind the murder of her closest blood
relative was justified and that she was
saving assault from a life that may have
led the girl to accept non-pure Bloods
or Worse Muggles as you can imagine
childhood with an aunt like gomla was
not a happy one for young adults for
results entire youth gomla kept her eyes
isolated in a Valley known as kumkali
forcing the young girl to watch as she
cursed any living thing that came their
way causing misery and pain to both her
victims as well as to poor results
gomlab also prevented her knees from
attending Hogwarts fearing that she
would only be exposed to Mud Bloods and
half-bloods in an all too tolerant
environment instead gomla took it upon
herself to teach his old magic although
she never permitted the girl to have her
own wand and kept her in line through
the use of dark magic gomla kept the
girl under this kind of restraint for
years it was over a decade before his
old was finally able to make her Escape
after she had fled gormla searched for
result for many years in vain determined
to find her niece so that she could go
back to enforcing her fervent
anti-mughal ideologies on the young
woman fortunately for result she was
able to travel undetected to North
America where she eventually fell in
love with a muggle and founded
ilvermorny a school of Witchcraft and
Wizardry which today has a reputation as
one of the most Progressive and tolerant
of its kind when news of this American
Wizarding School reached korma in
Ireland she deduced that her estranged
niece must be involved as ilvermorny was
the namesake of assault's first home the
one which gomla had destroyed when she
had murdered the girl's parents as you
can imagine gormla was Furious gormla
set out to America at once to seek her
revenge for the very thing she had hoped
to prevent seemed to have come true
assault was not only tolerant of Muggles
she was in love with one a James Stewart
the two had even gotten married and had
two twin girls Martha and riyanok upon
her arrival at ilvermorny gomla
attempted to use her parcel tongue and
dark magic abilities to murder result
and her husband James thankfully her
plans were foiled by two teenage Wizards
Chadwick and Webster whom result and
James had adopted The Power of Love and
the pakwachi named William who resulted
befriended many years previous
ultimately it was the pakwaji a magical
being native to America and distantly
related to the Goblins of Europe who
killed gomla with one of his poisonous
arrows if you ask me it was a fitting
end for which most evil a woman who had
spent her entire life in the pursuit of
purebred Supremacy at any cost including
murdering members of her own family and
holding a niece hostage for years with
the use of dark magic was killed with a
fatal arrow to the heart a poisonous
arrow for a poisonous heart seems like
Poetic Justice was it not and that
brings us to the end of this video what
do you think does all this rightfully
give gorm Lagoon to the title of most
evil witch in the Harry Potter universe
or is there another wedge that I've
overlooked let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and to subscribe to the channel until
next time those cunning folks use any
mean to achieve their ends
[Music]